Prior to 1906, when the Pure Food and Drug
Act was passed, there were no regulations
regarding the ethical use of human subjects in
research. There were no consumer regulations,
no Food and Drug Administration (FDA), no Common
Rule, and no Institutional Review Board (IRB).
Nuremberg Code.
A well-known chapter in the history of research
with human subjects opened on December 9, 1946,
when an American military tribunal opened criminal
proceedings against 23 leading German physicians
and administrators for their willing participation
in war crimes and crimes against humanity. Among
the charges were that German physicians conducted
medical experiments on thousands of concentration
camp prisoners without their consent.
Most of the subjects of these experiments
died or were permanently crippled as a result.
As a direct result of the trial, the
Nuremberg Code was established in 1948,
stating that "The voluntary consent of the human
subject is absolutely essential," making it clear
that subjects should give consent and that the
benefits of research must outweigh the risks.
Although it did not carry the force
of law, the Nuremberg Code was the
first international document which advocated
voluntary participation and informed consent.
Thalidomide
In the late 1950s, thalidomide
was approved as a sedative in Europe; it was
not approved in the United States by the FDA.
The drug was prescribed to control sleep and
nausea throughout pregnancy, but it was soon
found that taking this drug during pregnancy
caused severe deformities in the fetus. Many
patients did not know they were taking a drug that
was not approved for use by the FDA, nor did they
give informed consent. Some 12,000 babies were
born with severe deformities due to thalidomide.
U.S. Senate hearings followed and in 1962 the
so-called "Kefauver Amendments" to the Food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act were passed
into law to ensure drug efficacy
and greater drug safety. For the first
time, drug manufacturers were required
to prove to FDA the effectiveness of
their products before marketing them.
Tuskegee Syphilis Study (1932-1972)
An equally well known chapter in history occurred
during a research project conducted by the U.S.
Public Health Service. Six hundred low-income
African-American males, 400 of whom were infected
with syphilis, were monitored for 40 years.
Free medical examinations were given; however,
subjects were not told about their disease.
Even though a proven cure, penicillin, became
available in the 1950s, the study continued until
1972 with participants being denied treatment.
In some cases, when subjects were diagnosed
as having syphilis by other physicians,
researchers intervened to prevent treatment.
Many subjects died of syphilis during the study.
The study was stopped in 1973 by the U.S.
Department of Health, Education, and Welfare.
Declaration of Helsinki
In 1964, the World Medical Association established
recommendations guiding medical doctors in
biomedical research involving human subjects. The
Declaration governs international research ethics
and defines rules for "research combined with
clinical care" and "non-therapeutic research."
The Declaration of Helsinki was revised in 1975,
1983, 1989 and 1996 and is the basis
for Good Clinical Practices used today.
Issues addressed
in the Declaration of Helsinki include:
• Research with humans should be based on the
results from laboratory and animal experimentation
• Research protocols should be reviewed by an
independent committee prior to initiation
• Informed consent from research
participants is necessary
• Research should be conducted by
medically/scientifically qualified individuals
• Risks should not exceed benefits
The Belmont Report
Finally, The Belmont Report was published
in 1979, with attempts to summarize the
basic ethical principles identified by the
Commission in the course of its deliberations.
The Report is a statement of the basic ethical
principles and guidelines that should assist in
resolving the ethical problems that surround
the conduct of research with human subjects.
The Belmont Report established three basic ethical
principles – respect for persons, beneficence,
and justice – which are the cornerstones for
the regulations involving human subjects.